[Music]
those who are familiar with my content
know that i'm a big dungeon guy not only
did i make a couple of videos on the
topic but the very first word i ever
uttered on this channel was literally
the word dungeons it's by far one of my
favorite elements in video games there's
something about entering a dark cave or
ancient crypt not knowing what lies
ahead that really gets me fired up it
calls back memories of a time when i
used to go out and explore abandoned
buildings with my friends something i
don't do anymore nowadays mostly because
my wife doesn't want me to so for me
video games are the next best thing it
shouldn't come as a surprise then that
one of my favorite areas in eldon ring
are the catacombs which are these
optional mini dungeons located all over
the map mostly tucked away inside
canyons or hidden along cliffsides they
are creepy dimly lit and sometimes
surprisingly complex and challenging
especially those found in the mid to
late game this kind of stuff is my jam
it doesn't matter how many games i play
i will always have a soft spot for
dungeon crawling like this so when i
discovered my first catacomb and
realized what it was well let's just say
my excitement was to die for
now initially i actually discovered the
catacombs completely by accident the
result of me obsessively searching every
nook and cranny on the map to find
secrets and things of interest it wasn't
until about a quarter of the way into my
first playthrough that i realized you
can actually interact with these statues
and when you do they project a beam of
light that guides you towards a nearby
crypt some of you will think i'm an
idiot for finding this out so late into
the game and i probably am but i had
successfully avoided spoilers as much as
humanly possible so i had little to no
prior knowledge going in and i'm still
glad i did because figuring out how the
game works on my own was a big part of
the enjoyment for me there's probably a
hint somewhere that explains the statues
maybe in one of the loading screens or
the strategy guide or something but if
there is it went right over my head
there's plenty to cover about the
catacombs and today i want to focus
primarily on the level design and how
fromsoft manages to present a fun and
engaging dungeon experience purely
through smart enemy placement and
navigational challenge i'll even throw
in some basic lore to set the mood do
keep in mind that there will be spoilers
regarding some locations and puzzle
solutions if you're still playing or
planning to and want to figure it all
out on your own i advise coming back
later and to those who decide to stay
well grab your torch or strap on your
pocket lantern or both as we venture
below ground into the crypts of the
lands between
the story behind the catacombs is that
they were built for those who earned
themselves a proper death which
according to a lingering spirit inside
one of the crypts means that your soul
or essence is called back to the roots
of the earth tree see death is a bit of
a strange phenomena in alden ring when
the earth tree was still in its infancy
the current ruler of the lands between
queen america basically decided that she
didn't like the concept of dying as such
she took the rune of death from the
elden ring and gave it to her
half-brother malakath who would go on to
bind it into his sword this essentially
removed the concept of death from the
lands between and those touched by the
grace of the urtry including marika
herself and her demigod children were
able to enjoy a form of immortality it's
a bit of a complicated topic but from
what i understand you could still die in
the flesh but as long as your soul
remained intact and you had grace on
your side you could simply return to the
earth tree to be born anew and as for
malacath he became a sort of grim reaper
the only living being capable of dealing
true death at the hands of his black
blade and thus he was feared by everyone
including the demigods this is why all
catacombs feature tree roots snaking
along its walls and ceilings most
notably inside the boss chamber these
roots are directly connected to the
earth tree itself and the catacombs were
purposely built close to them to ease
the transition into the next life for
those laid to rest here also known as an
ur tree burial which was seen as a great
honor and privilege the many traps and
certain enemies like the imps and the
urgery burial watchdogs were put in
place to ward off grave robbers and
prevent the disturbance of these sacred
sites still some managed to circumvent
these security measures in the past the
watchdog's greatsword for example states
that the eye engraving is missing its
gem due to grave robbery we also find a
ghost in front of one of the catacombs
who complains that their resting place
has been violated clearly not everyone
respected the integrity of these sacred
burial sites
things really went south when a group of
assassins stole a fragment of the rune
of death from malakath and used it to
kill one of america's demigod children
godwin the golden the first demigod to
truly die since the establishment of
america's reign an event which became
known as the night of the black knives
however for reasons that are currently
not entirely clear godwin perished only
in seoul yet his body remained alive
somehow transforming him into the very
first undead or those who live in death
as they are commonly referred to
basically a being who lives on without a
soul his body was laid to rest at the
central roots of the earth tree right
below the capital perhaps with the faint
hope that he would still find his way
back to the earth tree somehow or that
he would still find some sense of peace
in the afterlife this action although
probably well intended inadvertently
caused an infection to spread across the
entire root system and soon after more
undead started rising from the grave
across the lands between including
inside the catacombs spooky so yeah
that's the basic story behind the
catacombs and why they became infested
of course it also serves as an excuse to
have creepy enemies present in the first
place after all you can't have a classic
dungeon like this without at least
having some zombies and skeletons in
there somewhere so let's switch gears
and leave the lore behind and instead
talk about dungeon design and what makes
them so effective
what i love most about the catacombs
well aside from the haunting music and
creepy atmosphere is its sheer
simplicity it's impressive how fromsoft
manages to do a lot with so very little
the process inside the catacombs is
essentially always the same there's a
big door leading to the boss which upon
entering is closed and can only be
unlocked by activating a switch you
navigate a maze full of enemies and
traps find the lever to open set door
after which you make your way to the
boss and defeat it
or you know not it's a very basic setup
and it may sound repetitive if you've
never played elder ring yourself but
you'd be surprised how much of a
difference little changes and some
clever tricks can make to the experience
in many ways they remind me a lot of the
classic labyrinths found in the original
zelda on the nes in fact i can imagine
that for a lot of kids back in the day
this is what the underground labyrinths
probably looked like in their
imagination i mean with graphics like
these you kinda had to fill in the
blanks of course there had to be a zelda
comparison in here somewhere i mean it
is the focal point of my channel after
all and sometimes when doing an analysis
it helps to stick to familiar territory
but there's a good reason why i'm
comparing the catacombs to the very
first zelda in particular and not to any
of the other installments in the zelda
series there's fundamental differences
between the more modern day zelda games
especially the 3d ones and the nes
original most notably for this analysis
the amount of interactivity with the
environment and movement options with
every new installment the series slowly
expanded these aspects and its dungeon
design reflects that change more
interactivity and mobility means you can
also incorporate more complicated puzzle
mechanics and means of traversal into
the level design itself there's a lot of
complicated stuff going on here lots of
creative item utilization twisting
corridors walking on walls and ceilings
underwater mechanics physics puzzles
anything you can think of zelda has
probably tried it at some point but back
in the old days the technology that
allows for this kind of stuff obviously
didn't exist yet link's movement was
very basic to say the least and the
amount of interactivity was minimal so
as a dungeon designer what do you do in
a situation like this well you build a
maze of course instead of all the fancy
stuff seen in later titles nintendo had
to rely mostly on clever enemy placement
and wayfinding to create challenging
dungeon environments essentially the
labyrinth as a whole is the puzzle and
this is where the similarities between
the original zelda and eldon ring lie in
terms of dungeon design outside of
combat the character doesn't really have
all that many options at their disposal
you can't climb up ledges can't pick
things up like pots for example there's
no physics puzzles or items that
completely change your mobility and
because the game is built around
character customization and different
builds it cannot even take into account
whether or not the player is in
possession of say a ranged weapon like a
bow so shooting a switch at long range
or cutting a rope with an arrow to lower
a drawbridge or something isn't really
an option either it's a much more
grounded experience i'm not saying eldon
ring rips off the original zelda by any
means nor is it meant to be an insult to
its gameplay i'm just saying that eldon
ring embraces that old school approach
to game and level design a callback to a
time when developers took a lot more
risks especially with things like
difficulty or hiding secrets so
incredibly well that you can't help but
ask yourself how people even managed to
find them in the first place the biggest
difference is that nowadays we have the
internet whereas back in the day gamers
were left to the mercy of gaming
magazines and physical strategy guides
but most of all it shows that you don't
always need complicated mechanics to
craft an enjoyable dungeon experience
eldon ring sticks to what from soft
games do best it keeps the focus on its
intricate battle system expansive rpg
elements creative enemy emboss design
challenging difficulty and the same
clever world design we've come to expect
from them ever since the first dark
souls now before we go any further and
discuss specific locations and puzzle
scenarios i have to briefly talk about
the online mode i hate to go a bit off
track but i just know that it's
something people will bring up if i
didn't at least mention it this might be
a cardinal sin in the eyes of veteran
souls players but if you're really into
exploration finding secrets and figuring
stuff out on your own i really feel like
elden ring is much more enjoyable when
playing offline at least for your first
playthrough that is of course if you're
into the pvp and co-op stuff leaving
messages and generally enjoy the
interaction with other players this
obviously doesn't apply to you for my
first playthrough i switched to offline
mode after about 6 hours of gameplay and
i never regretted that decision because
it can have a pretty significant impact
on how you experience dungeon
environments in particular the message
system as amazing and iconic as it is as
a series does tend to take away some of
the challenge it's a shame that there's
no option to simply hide the messages
while still playing in online mode and
instead you have to break the connection
to the server altogether which requires
going back to the title screen first now
you might say well just ignore the
messages you know don't read them and
while you can do that sometimes the mere
presence of a message can already spoil
too much for example there's a puzzle
where standing on a specific floor will
cause it to slowly move up into a
ceiling of spikes and you'll have just
the right amount of time to make it
across without getting impaled but doing
so only leads to an optional treasure
and it won't actually move you forward
instead you have to trigger the floor to
move quickly step away and pass
underneath the floor to find a secret
passage now i'll admit this isn't
exactly the hardest puzzle ever
conceived in a video game but i
generally got stuck here for quite a
while mainly because i wasn't able to
see anything below the moving floor this
may vary depending on your brightness
settings but all i saw was a faint
shimmer of water however past
experiences had taught me that water
usually kills you so as you can imagine
jumping into the void below and
potentially losing all my runes wasn't
exactly my first thought it also
happened to be my first encounter where
the game expects you to take a leap of
faith like this so i didn't know what
the rules were at this stage when i
talked to my cousin about this part of
the game he revealed that he knew to
jump down because he saw the glowing
messages other players had left at the
bottom and there's quite a few instances
in later parts of the game where you're
supposed to drop down to a lower level
or onto an obscure ledge things like
that so had i been playing in online
mode there's a very good chance that the
solution would have been given away
prematurely this is clearly a personal
preference maybe you didn't care about
it the way i did i just want to make
sure that when i'm talking about a
puzzle that i thought was smart or
difficult you at least keep in mind that
i wasn't seeing the messages anyway back
to the catacombs out of all dungeon
types in the game of which that
do you hear my chickens my chickens are
making a noise
do you hear that
hold on
alrighty then
out of all dungeon types in the game of
which there's quite a few like caves
castles and mansions only 17 are
classified as catacombs additionally
there's also 5 hero graves which are
pretty similar and even have the same
music track but are also different
enough that i would count them as
separate generally speaking the
catacombs are more claustrophobic and
labyrinthian whereas the hero graves are
more akin to an obstacle course a race
to the finish and most of them don't
even require you to flip a switch to
open up the boss door there are some
exceptions in overlapping themes and
mechanics but for this video i will
stick to the regular catacombs despite
repeating that same process of finding
the lever to open up the door to the
boss there's just enough variation to
keep them from feeling repetitive
sometimes the door is found close to the
entrance and the switch is somewhere
deep inside the maze other times it's
the other way around and the switch is
right at the beginning they can be in
plain sight or they can be very well
hidden some are straightforward while
others are confusing and frequently
branch off into multiple directions or
have a lot of optional rooms or trap
rooms you never actually have to visit a
few even straight up mess with you in a
clever way this isn't to say that every
catacomb is something to write home
about some definitely stick out more
than others which is why i'm not going
to go over every single one of them
individually the murk water catacombs
for example are painfully short and easy
it's one room then a corridor leading to
two more rooms one with the switch and
the other the door to the boss that's it
there's only one enemy type no secret
passages no traps of any kind nothing
but it is found in the early game so i
can forgive it for that what's cool is
that the game never actually explains or
hints at a solution or possibility
there's not a single instance where say
a cutscene plays to highlight something
or some sort of sign that gives you the
solution instead it lets you figure it
out for yourself by means of
experimentation and exhausting options
or if you do play online by players
sharing information with each other as
you progress through the game and tackle
more and more catacombs and other
dungeon types you'll slowly build up
knowledge on the various types of tricks
the developers can use to throw you off
and since they can be done out of order
you'll keep stumbling into new
situations you haven't encountered
before at some point you'll discover
that hitting one of these fire breathing
statues will deactivate them and make
them sink into the floor then in order
to progress in a later dungeon you'll
have to deactivate one jump on top of it
and then reactivate it to reach a floor
above you many locations feature one or
more rooms with guillotines which
obviously have to be avoided only to
have one catacomb mix it up and you'll
have to ride one of the blades up to
reach a new hallway there are several
instances where the way forward is
hidden underneath an elevator and
similar to the spike floor i mentioned
before you'll have to trigger the
elevator to move up and then step away
from it so you can go underneath none of
these puzzles are particularly
groundbreaking on their own but the way
the game progressively introduces new
mix-ups ensures that the solution isn't
always obvious it all depends on past
experience it's not until after you
found the solution for the first time
that you'll know to always check every
elevator in the future or to look for
fake walls when the room seemingly
doesn't lead anywhere it's exactly
because many of these dungeons can be
done out of order and are completely
optional that players will have vastly
different experiences depending on which
kind of situations they've encountered
up to that point for instance i got
stuck for way longer than i care to
admit inside the caled catacombs which
mind you is very very small it doesn't
even branch off it's a straight shot to
the boss door however the switch to open
the door is hidden inside a central
pillar of the room right before it and
up to this point in my playthrough i
hadn't come across a single illusory
wall yet so yeah suffice it to say i was
thrown off for a good couple of minutes
of course once i knew this was going to
be a thing inside the catacombs finding
fake walls became more intuitive there's
even one instance in the black knife
catacombs where there's a secondary boss
fight hidden behind one of these walls
pretty sneaky and there's much more
where that came from where one specific
catacomb does something none of the
others do a couple that stand out are
the ariza sai tomb which is the only
crypt that features these transported
chests that warp you all over the place
the war dead catacombs where there's a
literal ghost war going on a battle
between long dead heroes who continue to
duke it out in the afterlife and you
stuck in between trying to survive this
madness and find your way across and my
personal favorite the giant mountaintop
catacombs found in the late game which
to me is the perfect example of smart
level design without the use of complex
gameplay mechanics as you progress
through this place you eventually reach
a point where you feel like you're going
in circles and well technically you are
you'll seemingly cross the same rooms
and hallways over and over again
fighting the same type of enemies and if
you don't realize what's going on you
could be here for a while turns out that
many rooms have almost identical copies
with only a few differences that give
them away one enemy may be different or
missing or a statue is no longer there
hallways that used to go somewhere now
lead to a dead end all of a sudden
there's basically an entire section that
mirrors an earlier part of the structure
even after you realize that this room
and this one are not the same there's
still a good chance that you'll miss the
way forward because it becomes uncertain
what you have or haven't checked already
by the time you made it this far into
the game you'll no doubt be aware of the
elevator trick by now and before you
reach the part that loops you around
endlessly you'll first come across two
separate elevators the first one
actually serves as a double elevator and
will take you deep down into an
extensive basement level but you'll
quickly find that it doesn't lead to
anything except some optional treasure
the second one has nothing underneath
just a bottomless void from here you'll
cross the first set of duplicate rooms
but you're still on track at this point
if you were to turn back now you would
still make it back to the entrance it's
not until you drop down this hole in the
wall that you'll end up in the endless
loop once you get stuck in the loop the
game will attempt to fool you into
thinking that this elevator and this one
are one in the same they look identical
and each one brings you to a section
that looks similar the only difference
is that one leads to a dead end and the
other is where you actually came from
this presents the real possibility that
you might skip on checking below this
elevator because in your mind you've
already checked it before and there was
nothing there while in reality it was a
different elevator all along it's a
simple yet brilliant setup there's
another catacomb that does something
similar and even goes as far as
presenting you with a fake boss chamber
to throw you off there's many more
examples i could list but in terms of
navigation i think you get the point the
secondary challenge to all of this is of
course the survival aspect enemies and
traps will drain your hp with every hit
and once you run out of resources
there's nothing more you can do there's
no health drops little to no checkpoints
and death usually means going back to
the grace at the entrance not only that
but with the exception of some mini
bosses all enemies will respawn so
you're essentially back to square one
they also have a nasty habit of hiding
enemies sneakily around the corner
waiting to strike this happens so many
times it drives me nuts but i do realize
that this was done to always keep you on
your toes and discard you from just
waltzing all over the place so i can't
really complain about it all you have to
stay alive is your healing flask and if
you have a magic build the occasional
healing spell for as long as you have fp
to spare you can smash all the pots you
want but you're not going to be finding
any hearts any time soon the only way to
replenish your healing supplies is by
going back to the entrance and resting
at the grace but this too will cause
enemies to respawn so it's a trade-off
between dying and potentially losing all
your runes or resetting all the enemies
you've worked so hard for to kill the
only form of mercy the dungeon has is
that once you've unlocked the boss door
it'll stay open regardless if you die
rest at the grace or leave the area
entirely so once you pull that lever you
can rest assured knowing that you don't
have to go back and do it again and you
can just shoot straight for the boss
instead certain traps you've deactivated
like these fire breathing statues will
also remain as such and finally there
are some instances where the boss is
either so far away from the entrance or
the road to it is treacherous enough
that the game does give you a break by
placing a checkpoint in close proximity
to the boss which is a godsend in a game
where beating a boss on the first try is
not a common occurrence for most people
i do have to say that in regards to
combat challenge for me personally the
catacombs are more enjoyable if you're
not too over leveled maybe even slightly
under leveled dare i say it made me much
more observant patient and careful in my
gameplay choices i made much more use of
stealth trying to take as little damage
as i possibly could either avoiding
enemies altogether or picking them off
one by one to reduce the risk of getting
swarmed by a group which is never a good
time luckily the catacombs do scale in
difficulty depending on where you find
it usually the more late game the area
the tougher the enemies inside some
bosses even show up as normal enemies
later on like the watch dogs and the
cemetery shade but there were a few
instances where i was definitely way too
powerful either because i went back to
an early game area or i didn't find it
until after i already beaten the game
and this definitely confirmed for me
that being too overpowered can ruin part
of the experience i enjoyed myself a lot
more when i was on edge nervously
sneaking from room to room once you're
able to slash your way through almost
anything without resistance it does lose
its charm a bit i don't really have much
to say about enemy variety i think we
can all agree that imps are the worst
and they should all die in a raging barn
fire but lore wise it does make sense
for them to be present in almost every
catacomb after all they're supposed to
be guardians who protect them the same
goes for the burial watchdogs who are
here for the same reason there's
definitely quite a bit of recycling here
in the boss department but let's be fair
if you're complaining about a few reused
bosses in a game that has like what 120
of them of which 109 are completely
unique it's kind of hard not to sound
like a snob i'd say overall there's
enough enemies of various types to keep
it enjoyable i mean after breath the
wild which had the same robots in almost
every dungeon i'm easily satisfied and
that's about all i have to say thank you
for listening to me rambling on about
dungeon crawling and level design if you
guys don't mind i will save the shout
outs for new patreons and channel
members for an upcoming video because i
kind of ran out of time for this one so
to all the newcomers i apologize and i
hope you can wait a few more days oh and
in case you didn't see my latest
community post after about two years of
dodging the bullet i have finally fallen
victim to covid you have no idea the
amount of honey infused beverages i had
to ingest just to make this voice over
possible anyway starting next week i'm
going to be working on a new zelda
theory which i'm very excited for so i
hope to see you then this is dawn
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you